[Music]
what up guys goes in here for anime
uproar and in the last video about Momo
which did way better than I thought it
would thank you for that
I asked you what video you guys wanted
to see next some of you just said do all
the characters which was awesome and I
mean as long as you guys enjoyed them I
have no problem with making more but
more specifically a lot of you requested
or chaco so I thought that that would be
a good next one because we recently did
the other two popular best girl
contenders to you and Momo if you do
enjoy these videos make sure let me know
by Texas smashing that like button and
subscribe and join the notification na
kama by ringing that magic YouTube Bell
for the next video I'm straight-up gonna
let you guys vote for which character I
do
I made an Instagram and Twitter post
asking you the rules are you can only
vote once by writing down the name of
the character you want to see next in
the comments section of either to
Instagram or Twitter post liking other
people's comments does not count as a
vote you have to actually run out the
name and that way we know no one voted
more than once I will add the numbers up
and do a video about the winner so go
vote this should be fun I'll link to
Instagram and Twitter in the description
and also pinned a comment for you now
without further ado on to the video fact
number one there are actually multiple
ways to spell which echos name Oh Chico
erotica has actually been spelled in two
different ways within official material
in the manga or Chico was spelled with a
k which makes more sense in my opinion
since it is the same sound made by the K
in erotica which is always felt the same
and the romanized version of the
Japanese name would traditionally have a
K there alternatively in the anime they
replaced the K with a C so the C makes a
K sound like the name Rebecca kind of a
weird change in my opinion but I'm just
glad that they didn't change bothwell's
first name to Katsuki fact number 2 or
chuckles name is especially meaningful
to the creator of my hero academia KO
hey ho Takashi when talking about her
name what he Cauchy has said and I quote
when I struck up
on her name it was the first time I ever
generally thought wow I'm a genius of
myself it just suits her so perfectly
Veronica means bright and clear or
pretty day it is clear why this name
works well with her character what of
course she even mentioned that she can
be unexpectedly brazen and Frank because
there is no hidden side to her so she is
super clear in that sense she isn't
hiding anything this is why I personally
believed that she could never be the you
a traitor even though some of you
suggested that she might be it would be
a crazy twist but she's too see-through
or put a different way she's too honest
and her intentions are too obvious so
she couldn't pull off being a deceptive
traitor
ironically I suspect to literally see
through character Tohru more than I
suspect that figuratively see through or
chuckle the name Veronica is also a
homophone which is when different words
have the same pronunciation for
beautiful in Japanese on the other hand
for Chico literally means T girl which
reflects her bubbly personality
additionally the name can also be
derived from a word meeting chatterbox
girl this works great for her character
because Oh Chico is a talkative
conversation starter and hoodie cause
she knew that she would have to be
otherwise deco and her would never start
up conversations and become as close as
he wanted them to after all at the
beginning of the story deck was so shy
with girls that he considers being
embarrassed and not really saying
anything to be the same as talking to a
girl fact number three Oh Chico changed
quite a bit from horikoshi initial
drafts for my hero academia for starters
she was called you not or choco or
Chico's hair is also different from
horikoshi she's initial sketch but so is
her personality and even her quirk or
Chico was initially supposed to have
mount lady's quirk but then Holocaust
she thought it through and came to the
conclusion that someone in the so-called
main heroine role whose power was
Giganta fication would just come under
tons of stress from how much she'd stand
out and become a rather dark character
what he cost she changed her quirk to
zero gravity and gave her a light and
bubbly personality along with it
I definitely agree with this change
since I definitely prefer the
usually beaming or chuckle to a frowning
one as you can see while Chico's hero
costume also changed from earlier
designs which brings us to fact number
four for the most part or Chico's hero
costume is designed solely to help her
fend off nausea her quirks biggest
weakness if she uses her quirk too much
she will get sick and throw up leaving
her out of commission what's impressive
is that she can take objects that weigh
about three tons and make them
weightless using her quirk but if she
uses the power on herself
it makes her woozy to the point of
vomiting very quickly because of this
the costume was designed to keep her
from getting to that point as long as
possible
for instance around the wrist she has
devices that clamp down and release like
when someone is taking your blood
pressure and this stimulates the
pressure points around the wrist area
which suppresses the nausea similarly a
contraption around her neck stimulates
pressure points in order to reduce
headaches also her boots change from her
initial hero design they are much bigger
now because they are designed to break
her Falls there's a shock absorbing
cushion at the front of each of boot and
a reinforced spring in the back that
also softens the shock of her landing I
gotta say I really like our Chico's hero
costume design make sure let me know
who's hero costume is your personal
favorite in the comment section below
fact number five or chuckles quirk is
similar to sugar Aki's and that they
both need to touch something with all
five fingers of one hand for the
respective quirks to activate luckily
for Deku that's where the similarities
end however let's get more specific it's
not simply our Chico's fingers that need
to touch the object in question but a
specific part of her fingers her fingers
are actually different from other
people's our heroine has five soft
breezy little pads on the tips of her
fingers it is when she touches something
with all five pads at the same time that
she can remove the things gravitational
pull doing so we'll leave it floating in
the air weightless she is able to
release the effects of her quirk by
bringing the five pads of one hand into
contact with the corresponding five pads
of the other fact number six in regards
to popularity
no girl my hero academia has performed
as consistently well as or chaco let's
just stop for a sec and appreciate how
cool it is that there are popularity
polls in manga I wish we had more
popularity polls growing up in the West
like I'd be curious to see who's the
most popular Arthur a character or
weekenders character or even Simpsons
character just kidding about that last
one obviously it's Hank Scorpio but
that's in the past and now back to the
future while Momo never broke into the
top 10 most popular MHA characters
Portugal is the only girl that never not
once fell below 10th place in either the
Japanese or US popularity polls which is
saying a lot in the first Japanese poll
she got fourth then 10 then ninth while
in the first u.s. popularity poll she
got third and then 7 she was also the
highest ranking female character for the
most voted mhm a popularity poll of all
time which was released by crunchyroll
this year and had almost 40,000 votes in
this poll she got fourth and she won the
award for best girl in the 2017
crunchyroll Awards beating out all of
the girls from not only MHA but also
from all of the other anime that year so
congrats the horikoshi for managing to
create such a cross culturally beloved
character fact number 7 for this fact
let's look at or Chico's official stats
which are not that impressive
surprisingly despite the fact that or
Chico is our so-called main heroine she
got an unimpressive 2 out of 5 in power
she is one of the slowest characters
scoring a 1 out of 5 and speed her
intelligence is also not that impressive
she scored a 3 out of 5 and she got 13th
out of 20 in class one eighth grades
however she does in part make up for
these stats with perfect scores ie 5 out
of 5 in technique and cooperativeness
these latter scores help explain how she
managed to do so well in the UA entrance
exam where she got the third best result
to help put her scores into perspective
her overall score is 16 out of 25 or 64%
compared to someone like Momo who got an
overall score of 20 out of 25
or 80% clearly or choco is not the most
gifted you a student but there's much
more to hurt than these statistics which
as we saw have not hurt her popularity
fact number 8 Oh Chico is voiced in the
original Japanese dub by the 24 year old
Ayane Sakura she has been in many anime
including psycho-pass your lie in april
and overlord near the beginning of her
career one of the first roles she got in
anime was as a sales clerk in an Ohana
which aired in 2011 making Ayane about
17 years old at the time
side note check out on Ohana if you
haven't because it's a must watch field
trip anyways although she's still young
it's clear that Ayane Sakura has
definitely come a long way as a voice
actress or say you fact number 9 in the
English dub or choco is voiced by the 45
year old Lucy Christian she is also a
scriptwriter for dubbed anime at
Funimation in addition to watch EKKO she
voiced Nami in the one piece dump and in
the Clannad dub she voiced Nagisa food
Okawa who is actually one of my favorite
anime characters while Clannad is one of
my favorite anime definitely another
field trip you need to check out if you
haven't
make sure let me know if you prefer or
chucko subbed or dubbed in the comments
fact number 10 like last time instead of
one fact I'll do a lightning round of
multiple random facts here because who
doesn't love bonus facts
Ready Set let's go what chuckle is one
of the shortest characters in MHA at 156
centimeters or 5 foot one and a half
inches which place is heard between Jiro
and takoyaki her blood type is B and she
likes Japanese cuisine so it's extremely
lucky that she was born in Japan of all
places she also likes starry night skies
but I'm sure she'd like them even more
if Deku was stargazing with her
lastly her birthday is December 27 so
two days after Christmas it is probably
because her birthday is so close to
Christmas that horikoshi has made
Twitter sketches of her in a Santa Claus
outfit twice once alone and once with
Momo and that is it for the facts and
now on to the comment corner like last
time with the Momo video I asked you on
Instagram what your favorite thing about
article was last time we got 70
six comments and this time we got well
over 100 in one day so I'm thankful the
instant community is growing so quickly
and thank you to everyone who shared
their thoughts let's jump into some
responses right now it's Roz knee says
my favorite thing about her is her in
Midori --is chemistry and dynamic when
they are together and for a lot of you
your favorite thing was the relationship
between our main hero deku and our main
heroine or choco comment ship or skip in
the comments section below depending on
how you feel about this pair I
definitely ship it Portugal was the
first girl from class 1a that deku
encountered which is probably a little
wink from horikoshi and their feelings
for each other seem pretty obvious I
will be shocked if they don't end up
together Benjamin says or choco can
literally and figuratively lift people
up I like what you did there brother
it's or choco also likes how she is
always happy and brings joy out of
everyone I agree I love the fact that
she is such an optimistic positive
character it's crazy to think that she
could have been a dark character if
horikoshi hadn't changed his mind about
her fellow Ana tuber the anime dude says
she seems kind of cutesy and laid-back
but not only is she well grounded she's
got a fire hidden under that deceptive
exterior I always find it funny when
people say she's well grounded because
her quirk ironically takes her off the
ground but nonetheless I see your point
and I definitely agreed that she's got a
fire inside and I think that the
tournament arc did an amazing job of
bringing that side out of her her battle
against ba kugel was amazing and even
though she lost I feel like she
surprised everyone with her performance
potatoes oh one two three likes when she
gets jealous when Mae touches deku too
adorable I 100% agree
those moments are the best real Sun dot
likes her reason for wanting to be a
hero few students are as honest as she
is when it comes to personal life some
of you didn't like the fact that she
wanted to become a hero for money but a
lot of you respected her honesty and her
desire to give back to her parents I
fall in the latter category myself
although she is doing it for the money
money is just a means to an end to help
out her parents
and I don't personally think there's
anything wrong with that plus I really
like how open and honest she is about
her motives and that's it for the
comment corner section of this video
thanks again to everyone who submitted
comments on the post and you can totally
go there now and read the rest there are
really good ones and I'm sorry I can't
fit them all into the video but rest
assured I always make sure to read them
all I'll do something similar for every
MHA faq video so definitely join the
insta famine to participate in future
videos thanks so much for watching make
sure to vote for the next video on
Instagram or Twitter hopefully you learn
something new about or chaco and can
appreciate her even more than you did
before if you liked the video make sure
the Texas smash that like button if you
haven't already you can join the
notification naca mob by subscribing and
ringing that magical bell and until next
time see ya space Cowboys
[Music]